okay so
this is the one that was
that was shown in my feed
um
when
i did the upload so
i don't know who this chick is what's
her name
jamie date
um so let's pause give this some volume
and let's hear what she's got to offer
guys on the exact same article so it's
so it's kind of like she's superimposed
in front of it and she's offering the
feedback so let's just play this and
i'll uh i'll chime in
i've had a lot of people want me to do
videos about this so let's [ __ ] go
i'm a female dating coach for men and
like 98 of my audience is male so i want
to offer some insight by no means am i
trying to start arguments actually what
the [ __ ] am i saying of course there's
gonna be arguments okay here it goes
right off the bat in first 15 seconds
she's
she's got like that trailer trash mouth
man like just like just the language
that she used is not appealing but i
guess maybe she's trying to appeal the
guys by using a lot of swear words
immediately i don't know
women don't need men like how they used
to so what does that mean for men i mean
women couldn't even open okay so she's
right about that women don't need men
the way that they used to you know you
know like i said in my video like
there's a lot of women today that are
going on about i need a man like a fish
needs a bicycle sort of thing right so
she's accurate about that but just
listen to the rest of this because
because it really does go sideways went
up a bank account until like the 1970s
and you know here we go with like you
know the victim mindset women couldn't
open up a bank account until like the
1970s
well women were in the workforce well
before then which meant they had to have
a bank account so
i don't know what that's all about but
you're going to hear it in a second when
she talks about the wage gap now open up
a bank account to like the 1970s not to
mention we're still trying to close the
wage gap in 2022.
so
i can't believe i just heard that but
she legitimately said that there's a
wage gap in 2022 and that there's a 17
percent difference was that what it said
on the screen 17
that women make 17 less than men boo
freaking who and that's been dispelled a
million freaking times
but here we are female dating coach
heterosexual men have been first place
for a long time so now that our culture
has made you question that of course
there's gonna be a backlash on the male
side so let's break that down women
don't need a man's paycheck to live this
is a good thing women no longer have to
feel like they're sex objects and men no
longer have to feel like their success
object okay well where have we heard
that before right
i've only said it a million times
men are success objects women are beauty
objects we'll use
the segs objects as we kind of move
through this but that was determined by
dr warren farrell uh he's mentioned a
number of time in times in his research
papers he's got some great books out
there uh the myth of male power is a
very good one and she's telling her male
uh audience the the dating tips hashtag
dating tips for men dating coach for men
blah blah blah so she's positioning
herself as a men's dating coach and
she's lying to them right off the bat
now i don't know if she's lying to them
intentionally or she doesn't know what
she's talking about but she's not
delivering useful information right
she's she's basically telling her
audience you don't need to be a success
object and women don't need to be a
beauty object which is bs because it's
always been that way and it's always
going to be that way women choose men
based on their success like a woman is
interested in a man's future and there's
a reason why a man is interested in her
past because he wants purity right he
wants you know he wants the innocence
you know component that's why women are
considered beauty objects so her just
saying that women are no longer beauty
objects and men are no longer success
objects because of modern days it's a
disservice you know like right there at
the 43 second mark
it's it's it's just a full-on dismissal
but guys will watch it right because
she's a dating coach for men
win-win for everyone for the most part
so what was happening before is that
women were letting their men get away
with a lot because she needed his
paycheck to live now that women are
self-sufficient they're expecting more
from their men equal to what men expect
actually so she's saying that women
don't need his paycheck to live but
women don't date down
they generally don't marry down they
they generally don't date down it does
happen
rarely but they generally date across
across and up on the socioeconomic scale
and one of the things that i pointed out
in my video when i was feeding back on
that article was
you know 25 30 years ago maybe women
were here
and now more women are up here so that
leaves the gap between here and here
there needs to be more men above them
over here because women only date across
and up
so
you know to say that she doesn't need
his money is not true because if you
want to
have a family a parent needs to stay
home and usually the lower income
earning parent which is generally going
to be the mother because women are
hypergamous and they date across and up
i mean ask any divorce lawyer who is
usually the the stronger income earner
and the divorce lawyer always tells you
the same thing and vast majority of
cases it's always the guy
i did private mortgages for a number of
years
tons of them and i looked at a lot of
credit applications and i would see
where he worked and where she worked and
i would see their income and i would get
proof of income and
nine nine point five times out of ten he
was making more money than she was so
despite what she's saying
modern times and we're all equal and
egalitarian you know blah blah blah sort
of thing women still
need a man's paycheck to live especially
when it comes to building a family
they're expecting more from their men
equal to what men expect actually so
what do women want
well according to the article we want
emotionally available good communicators
and share similar values
so get this the reason why dating seems
so much harder for men nowadays is
because society did a really crappy job
in teaching men how to have deep
connections how to be good communicators
let me guess
she's going to teach you how if you just
pay her for a consultation i would
imagine right
like
i thought for a second there when i saw
the highlight and nowadays is because
society did a really crappy job in
teaching men haters and share similar
values like i thought for a second you
know she was going to crack a joke and
be like haha what a load of crap but no
she actually rolls with it right like
you know this is this is plugged in this
is plugged in the matrix you know this
is like bs this is what they want you to
believe right you have to be a good
communicator yeah because women swipe
right on your good communication skills
right
right come on
so get this the reason why dating seems
so much harder for men nowadays is
because society did a really crappy job
in teaching men how to have deep
connections how to be good communicators
this is what she's right about society
doing a crappy job but it has very
little to do with having deep
connections and being good communicators
but i digress let's keep going where
dating coaches come in but before my
shameless plug so to provide oh here
comes a shameless plug find an insight
to the frustration behind women when it
comes to dating and why we're looking
for better men is because in society we
are still expected to parent as if we
don't have work and work as if we aren't
a parent whereas men's work home balance
hasn't really changed that much women
are looking for you hear the victim
mindset you know infusions here right
we've heard it like three times so far
men to take that emotional and physical
labor some of it off of their plate
being good communicators and having
deeper connections shows us that you can
do that and for all the commenters
claiming that relationships aren't worth
it anymore hate to burst your bubble kid
but men are typically happier and
healthier when they're partnered
uh yeah that's debatable but let's
let's see what the hook is
no matter how hard you fight it you'll
always crave intimacy so what do men
have to do
men have a key role in this
transformation but only if they go all
in it's going to take that kind of
commitment to themselves their own
mental health to the kind of love they
want to generate in the world will you
step up i love the way this article ends
and honestly i believe you will you have
to
dating will never go back to the way
things were when it was easier because
that would mean taking away rights from
women which is kind of already happening
in america but
and again
you hear the victim mindset again taking
away
rights from women which is already
happening in america like
address and from my experience men are
emotional creatures in the best type of
way and you can learn to harness that
power to attract the exact woman that
you're looking for and i can teach you
how there you go shameless plug i had to
do it i can teach you how
i got you i got you guys i can teach you
how
so
that's the advice right wage gap women
don't need his money to live but she
does she says men and women are no
longer
success objects and sex objects
i don't know it's it's build a beta it's
build a better beta programming right
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you